hallo liebe leute wir sind gerade in san
francisco wir laufen durch die straßen
und wir drehen jetzt eine nacht episode
geantwortet weil heute freitag ist
vierteln die köpfe bald frei da ist
gerade auf man es ist freitag und wir
haben noch kein video gedreht
also los geht's das hast du fragen wir
uns
beschäftigt die leute also sind gestern
abend ankommen es ist jetzt freitag
morgen 9 uhr wir sind eben aufgeschlagen
haben das haus verlassen
die erste private ich muss das mikrofon
ich glaube dass wir den reichen also von
kate fragt einem neuen germanwings mit
nur auf der super easy german wir haben
uns natürlich total gefreut über die
ganzen positiven kommentare zum super
easy german haben wir unsere neue serie
ausgebracht die ist speziell für
anfänger und in der serie sprechen wir
ganz langsam mit untertiteln also das
ist wirklich für anfänger und alle fand
es toll und wir freuen uns euch
mitteilen zu können dass wir auf jeden
fall weitermachen
also es wird jetzt jeden mittwoch eine
episode von super easy german gehen
besonders freut sich ja ich freue mich
total weil nämlich auf diese weise ganz
schnell französisch und spanisch noch
dazulernen will und ich liebe diese
methode
es macht spaß jeden tag stellt ihr euch
vor wir haben 200 von solchen videos und
du kannst dir vornehmen jeden tag ein
video zu gucken und nach 200 tagen bist
du besser ich kann das dir garantieren
du bist dann besser und ich freue mich
dass haben wir noch eine frage war wie
bei 96 fragt eine frage kann
wie können sie die deutsche touristen
amerika wissen wenn möchten sie ihn
interviewen
er meint natürlich wie erkennen sie die
deutschen touristen wenn sie sie
interviewen wollen mit richtig liege
guck mal unsere episode aus polen
roger rinke mit pool und der martin und
ich geschrieben wie man deutsche
touristen erkennt meistens erkennt man
sie
sie ziemlich hässlich wie viel schief
nein deutsche sind tatsächlich wir gehen
tatsächlich rum und hören so ein
bisschen das heißt wir sind ja mal mit
einer gruppe unterwegs vier oder fünf
leute und wir stellen uns einfach mitten
in die leute rein und deutsch deutsche
reisen erhielt die sind an allen
touristen sports findet man sofort
deutsche
es ist ganz einfach man muss einfach nur
da hingehen weißes haus monument valley
wo waren wir noch walk of fame
sofort griff zum deutschen nächste frage
die tafel auf fragt hallo karin ich will
in bergheim gehen aber sven sagt immer
nein vielleicht bin ich nicht genug gras
wirst du mit mir gehen
du bist super krasse krass es natürlich
wird aber klar sagen dass er willens
berg eingehen aber sven sagt immer nein
und jetzt reichlich ist wenn der
türsteher oder dein freund warst du
schon mal ein berg ein
nein ich weiß nicht mal weiß ist
wahrscheinlich irgendwo in
süddeutschland wieder nein das ist ein
bekannter techno club in berlin
ganz krass ich werde sowieso nirgendwo
reingelassen mit meinem gesicht und mit
meinem bauch heißt das direkt weiter wer
hat es geschrieben
die klarstellung die tafel ich weiß auch
nicht ob ich dafür krass genug bin
natürlich bin ich ziemlich krass wieder
auch sehr gesagt was aber nicht so krass
also ich weiß wäre hätte ich das toll
fände vielleicht wir haben mal
reingucken aber ich wohne jetzt seit
feiern in berlin und war noch nicht da
und all die leute die schreiben dass sie
da waren von deren aussagen schließen
würde ich jetzt denken dass das nicht
unbedingt meine welt ist und ich glaube
wir sind zu weit gegangen oder madonna
nicht ich muss eigentlich mal auf die
auf die karten gucken
nächste frage mister linux user coronado
warum noch mal in die usa um die
hässliche akzent karin carina liebt die
dummen windows aber die zuschauer nicht
was sagst du dazu jannes ja wir lieben
die dummen gringos die sind gar nicht so
dumm und ich sind sehr freundlich und
die haben eine ganz hübsche kultur von
der wir alle profitieren was wir nun
können
und im moment sind wir bei den drinks
und trotzdem in eine latina viertel war
es hier mehr spanisch ist guckst du ja
und deshalb immer locker angehen man
radio havanna
kannst du mal kurz das halten es ist
sehr schwer geworden ich kenne noch
etwas dazu sagen ich habe mittlerweile
gelesen du kommst aus peru und wie du
weißt haben in peru auch freunde und
auch partner gerade ja also wir haben
freunde in aller welt und falls du dich
erinnerst unsere erste reise wo wir
videos im ausland gemacht haben war
namibia dann waren wir in polen in der
slowakei und österreich in der schweiz
und jetzt in den usa also fand zu vielen
orten und ja nach mexiko und wir würden
sehr gerne überall hinfahren ja nach
asien lateinamerika
es gibt keinen ort auf der welt wurde
nicht hinfahren wollen und wenn es leute
sowas schreiben dass sie amerikaner
passen weil wir und dass wir uns für
nichts anderes interessieren das stimmt
einfach nicht
wir interessieren uns für alle länder
interessiert es für alle menschen und
amerika hat uns einfach eingeladen wir
haben über 70 einladungen bekommen und
aus peru eben noch nicht und du kannst
das natürlich ändern
indem du uns ein netz überleg mal denkt
mal drüber nach nächste frage
ja
doch
schnell gegangen 57 minuten zeit für
valencia silencio fragt was denkt ja nur
über deutschland
was sind die nachteile und vorteile was
gefällt dir am meisten los und was
machst du nicht in deutschland
ich persönlich ich persönlich denke ich
persönlich denke dass die deutsche sind
am anfang ein wenig glück herhalten
aber dann sehr höflich und auf eine
komische weise sehr direkt und das finde
ich wie ein vorteil so janisch mutter
gefragt was er von deutschland denkst du
uns ja hier seit 30 jahren
aber wie geht also wie gesagt es gibt
immer ganz viele menschen die ganz
verschieden sind es ist schwierig
sondern allgemein eine generalisierende
urteile abzugeben aber dafür ernst du
wolltest doch nicht nach deutschland
kommen wollte es doch nie in deutschland
bleiben und dann bist du plötzlich
trotzdem 30 jahre dort geblieben du
musst doch etwas sagen können warum bloß
in deutschland marx und wenn ja warum
oder warum nicht ja also ich mag an
deutschland ganz ganz viel ist im grunde
jetzt mit 30 jahren bin ich auf jeden
fall ein bisschen ich bin auf jeden fall
sehr in deutschland verliebt dann nicht
ganz ganz ganz ehrlich sagen ich liebe
deutschland finde deutschland wunderbar
aber man muss schon wieder sagen ich
meine dabei halt meine leute die leute
die ich kenne die leute mit denen ich
verkehre
es gibt bestimmt in deutschland leute
die ich nicht unbedingt market mögen
würde aber wenn wenn du jetzt
eigenschaften eigentlich es spezielle
eigenschaften wissen würdest wissen
möchte es dann vielleicht am meisten die
ehrlichkeit tatsächlich das ist das was
du ja auch schon erwähnt hast also die
deutschen sind ehrlich und das bedeutet
sehr viel in sehr vielen das äußerst
sich auch in sehr vielen situationen ja
und das ist dass es irgendwie ist das
befreiend und und und einfach nett also
die die deutschen reden nicht um den
brei herum
deutsch also die reden nicht herum
drumherum die gehen wenn sie wenn die
deutschen etwas nicht gefällt dann sagen
sie das wenn du dich falsch verhält dann
kannst du damit rechnen dass die
deutschen oder deine deutsche freundin
das direkt sagt und das finde ich nicht
richtig das ist total nämlich was du da
machst
und außerdem sind sie freundlich laufen
zwar nicht so sehr wie die amerikaner
aber trotzdem sehr sehr freundlich und
polen quatschen zu viel hast du noch
eine frage
san francisco auch mein erster tag
ich weiß gar nicht wir sind im mission
district gallo sagte sie und band shake
out dann kalou drogba kalou der sehr
gute idee aber ihr sehen wenn sind nur
freunde
aber sie sind beide auf der suche nach
einer freundin oder einem freund
deshalb machen wir standen einen kleinen
aufruf wir wollen sie und wenn
verkuppeln die wissen das nicht dass wir
das jetzt machen
schickt uns doch mal wir stehen im weg
schickt uns doch mal vorschlägen wollt
ihr easy und beim kennenlernen
kennt ihr jemanden der isel bändchen wir
suchen jetzt wir machen jetzt datings
für ihren band aber ich glaube es mich
weil ich sie und wenn sind supergut der
freunde aber einig die beiden besuchen
unter den zuschauern einen neuen partner
für wen und für easy a a
schickt mir bitte die bewerbungen und 10
10 euro schutzgebühr also jannis kennt
die bewerbung ohne ohne schutzgebühr
ließ die bewerbung also wenn ihr easy
und ben kennenlernen wald schickt uns
doch bitte eure bewerbung an info at the
german dot org
wir hoffen dass dort viele dabei sind
und die witzigste bewerbung gewinnt ein
date würde ich sagen oder und jannis
sucht aus letzte frage also online media
fragt sich warum muss ich alle projekte
finanzieren um so viel spaß in amerika
zu
ohne mich eigentlich richtig gedacht na
ja wenn du uns unterstützt bist du in
der ortsgruppe dabei leid aber das muss
unser projekt nicht finanzieren
wir freuen uns wenn wir unterstützung
bekommen weil dass es eine möglichkeit
wie ihr an uns etwas zurück geben könnt
wenn ihr das wollt wir produzieren jede
woche videos quasi umsonst und das
tolles wir haben auf dieser tour
unglaublich viel unterstützung bekommen
und unglaublich viel warmherzigkeit und
freundlichkeit und da das ist einfach
der hammer und aber ich will dieses
unglaublich betonen weil das was das was
die leute für uns getan und getan haben
das ist schon unglaublich eben ja wie
wolf aus der wohnung auszieht für für
die er drei für die er sehr viele viel
geld bezahlt und dann bei freunden
übernachtet vier tage lang damit wir
gemütlich und umsonst in new york wohnen
können zum beispiel die a nati ist
eingeladen hat und einen mexican
barbecues anschein hat wir wollten
eigentlich gar nicht nach las vegas
fahren weil wir das gar nicht so sehr in
das ist so wunderschön interessant dass
wir nach las vegas fahren nicht wegen
dem junk dann nicht mehr gegen müll
sondern wegen der jana die uns zu
mexikanischen essen einlädt ist ja ist
das nicht wenn das wir wollten gar nicht
nach las vegas fahren dann bekommt eine
e mail von diana und sich schreibt ich
bin euer größter fan ist nach las vegas
kommen und ich werde einen mexican
barbecue für ich machen
und da wir eh mexikanisches essen sehr
gerne mögen haben wir gesagt okay wir
fahren nach las vegas und es war
wunderschön und sie ist dann nachts aus
ihrem schlafzimmer und ihr sohn auch
sind aus ihrem schlafzimmer ausgezogen
und haben damit wir schaffen auf dem
fußboden im wohnzimmer geschlafen damit
wir in einem bett schlafen kann mir
schon echt schlecht wo also ich habe mir
zumindest versprochen denn der ja
irgendwann nach berlin kommt sehe ich
sofort raus aus der wohnung und
nach denen sind wir auch weil oder die
bics die wohnung colorado und steril ist
zweifacher vater und hat uns erzählt
dass er besessen davon ist deutsch zu
lernen
und er hat uns einfach eingeladen nach
kleinmut springs einem kleinen ort in
colorado und hat und das hotel bezahlt
und zum essen eingeladen und wir haben
ihn kennengelernt und seine familie und
das war so nett ist einfach
diese reise ist einfach dankeschön dafür
sammelt kann eigentlich auch aufhören
oder wir haben zeigt uns noch was von
der umgebung okay damit können wir
eigentlich aufhören janosch ein
schlusswort von dir ein schlusswort
ja macht weiter so lernen deutsch und
kommuniziert mit uns und wir freuen uns
dass wir uns freuen das sieht ihr ja wir
freuen uns sehr und wir sind sehr
glücklich dass wir mit uns kommunizieren
wir freuen uns wenn ihr uns einladen es
kam übrigens nicht so viele einladungen
aus polen jan ich will kommt dass die
polen sind einig nach den usa das land
wo wir am meisten zuschauer haben
deswegen dachte mir vielleicht laden uns
da auch noch es ist bestimmt
komplizierter weil er ich glaube sie
haben keine wohnungen dafür
es ist schwierig wir haben drei oder
vier einladungen bekommen nach breslau
und krakau
ja das ist schon was und dann fahren wir
noch nach katowice und dann fahren wir
nach boston und dann machen wir ne
richtige tour in polen
danke dass ihr uns immer zuschauer dass
er uns unterstützt
wir werden demnächst auch eine passion
challenge machen das kündige ich schon
mal an aber ich erzähle nicht was das
ist
wenn ihr uns unterstützen möchte das ist
unsere ganze freude vorbei auf bachelor
dot com / german walke bist du schon
wir sagen tschüss von der st james
kirche in san francisco liebe grüße
youngsters den stoff alten liebe müsse
kinder sagen
durch das mal hier